all right tonight we are blowing this
case about Bruce or FISA abuse wide open
I've been on the phone with sources all
day and all night people who are in the
room during ORS testimony we did learn
today the Bruce or said that he
understood the steel dossier would never
have been accepted in a court of law
he understood it we have 65 pages of
notes and text and then meetings between
him and Christopher Steele he said the
FBI knew about the seedy relationship
with steel so much to cover stay with us
we'll break it wide open but there's no
doubt that a conspiracy to commit fraud
against FISA Court judges did in fact
take place now let's dive into the
testimony from Bruce sword today now
remember he is the twice demoted DOJ
official who once helped ex foreign spy
paid for by Hillary Christopher steel
spread all these anti-trump Russian lies
throughout the highest levels of our
government and today during a
closed-door hearing Bruce or was grilled
on the hill by members of the House
Oversight and the Judiciary Committees
for seven hours now the crucial issue at
play here is rampant FISA abuse
surrounding Christopher Steele's
dirty dossier with Russian lies that
Hillary Clinton illegally funneled
through a law firm into fusion GPS
hiring then Christopher Steele now our
sources say that that topic was front
and center at the hearing today get this
Sarah Carter is now reporting she'll
join us later that we now know that the
FBI was aware of Steele's blatant and
extreme anti-trump bias before they used
his dossier is the bulk of their FISA
Court applications remember Bruce or
even road Steele was quote desperate
that Donald Trump not get elected he was
passionate that Donald Trump not being
President of the United States sounds
just like Carter just like Paige and and
struck and Sarah Carter also reporting
that today's hearing proved that the FBI
was using Bruce or as a back channel for
Steele's anti-trump Intel even after the
FBI cut all formal ties with Christopher
Steele over trust issues and he's saying
that the FBI knew everything
and despite this Congressman John
Ratcliffe who was a part of today's
hearing is telling us that or was not
mentioned in any of the FBI FISA
applications against the Trump campaign
associate now congressman Ratcliffe
Sarah Carter Gregg Jarrett and John
Solomon will all be with us tonight this
is yet another sign of the FBI's blatant
effort to hide the true nature of
Clinton's bought and paid for Steele's
dirty Russian dossier
it was campaign op research it was
compromised
it was never verified or corroborated it
turned out to be lies Russian lies
funded by the Clinton campaign and the
DNC they funneled the money through a
law firm hiring fusion GPS that then
hired Christopher Steele an ex foreign
spy that had really seedy Russian
connections we now know who was working
with and fourth fusion GPS and by the
way was also on the FBI payroll this is
really the cherry on this top he was
working with Bruce Laura's wife Nellie
or the ORS were literally profiting off
their relationship with Christopher
Steele or said today that he disclosed
that to the FBI
really and the FBI was okay with that
now at the end this is where we are we
now know for a fact that in four
separate FISA Court applications FISA
Court judges will repeatedly lie to
knowingly lie to the American people you
were all lied to all in an effort by
high-ranking government bureaucrats to
steal sway Rob an election and at all
costs stop Donald Trump from winning and
then to destroy his presidency now
communications between or and
Christopher Steele 60 some on pages of
it it shows that Steele was extremely
concerned about being exposed for this
and for good reason
because this level of corruption and
abuse should make every single American
citizen sick a blatant example of what
I've been telling you a two-tier justice
system Hillary Clinton gets a free pass
Trump is literally targeted by our
government with her salacious phony
campaign op research put together by a
foreign national using Russian
sources for lies we have a brand new
article tonight from Gregg Jarrett he'll
be with us too he details how the
one-time FBI director James Comey took
control of the Clinton investigation
took it right out of the hands of the
field offices and twisted the facts
soften the language exonerated Clinton
rigged her investigation from the very
beginning they really never was an
investigation Clinton was never going to
be found guilty because she was the
favorite candidate and meanwhile the FBI
the Department of Justice they work
hand-in-hand with ex foreign spy
Christopher Steele to use his phony lies
to open an investigation into allegedly
Trump Russia collusion they gain these
FISA warrants illegally against a trump
campaign associate they potentially
leaked that information we know they
leaked it to the general public to sway
opinion with lives this is the stuff
that happened in the former Soviet Union
all of this despite everybody knowing
including or admitting today that
Steele's shady past that has worked for
the Clinton campaign that is blatant
bias against Trump that is leaks to the
press that he was let go by the FBI that
was also paying him
it's no wonder President Trump keeps
talking about a witch-hunt and he's
livid with his attorney general mr.
sessions where are you tonight why are
you standing by and literally doing
nothing to fix what is clearly a
horrific inequality in our justice
system
now today Senator Lindsey Graham he
summed it up best let's take a look word
of caution the felt like a lot of people
try to convicted president Trump don't
be so fast I've seen no evidence of
collusion after two years Muller is
looking at it we'll see what he says
plenty of corruption Department Justice
and the FBI should be stunning not one
Democrat seems to care reverse the roles
what corruption what do you mean okay
just imagine if the Republican Party had
hired a foreign agent to go to Russia to
get dirt on Hillary Clinton and they
used it to get a warrant and never told
the court about it I'd be front-page
story everywhere that's pretty corrupt
when the two FBI agent and the US
attorney purr I mean the deal
lawyer it's our job to stop Trump can
you imagine what would happen if it's
our job to stop Clinton now we have a
lot of breaking news tonight right here
in this program in other words we do
have news to break as it relates to
Russian collusion it's been found
I know Robert Muller cares about taxicab
medallions and old income tax reports
and loan applications maybe mr. Muller
should take note of what we're reporting
tonight because we have a new report
from John Solomon follow the bouncing
ball Bruce or the DOJ closely working
with a Putin linked Russian oligarch for
years and most recently the FBI tried to
squeeze the oligarch for information
surrounding Trump Russia collusion
including a theory that Paul Manafort
was leading Trump campaigns collusion
efforts by the way he'd been into a
lawsuit with Paul Manafort and even he
said that's ridiculous it's absurd and
according to Solomon the all oligarch
actually used the word preposterous now
think about this this is the same
Russian oligarch that the u.s. won't
even allow into the country he met with
Bruce or he met with other top officials
you've got to be kidding me
how much more insane does this get you
cannot make this up we reached out to or
the DOJ the Russian oligarch involved of
course we didn't get a response we're
going to have a lot more on all of these
issues all of the key players are
joining us tonight but meanwhile the
biggest cheerleader of Trump Russia
collusion has been caught red-handed yet
again reporting fake news to you the
American people in July fake news CNN
they broke a huge bombshell story
detailing shocking evidence about
Trump's involvement in the now infamous
2016 Trump Tower meeting we've got the
tape to remind you well Chris tonight
sources with knowledge tell myself and
Karl that Michael Cohen claims that then
candidate Donald Trump knew in advance
about the June 2016 meeting in Trump
Tower in which Russians were expected to
offer his campaign dirt on Hillary
Clinton crucially these sources tell us
that Cohen is willing to make that
assertion to the special counsel robert
muller it's very very significant
because the president has denied any
foreknowledge of this event and
meeting goes to the question of intent
to collude you've been saying for a year
that we need to follow the money follow
the lies and figure out this cover-up so
how did you do it in this case talk is
about how you got this reporting I
talked to sources Cohen was saying that
Donald Trump the candidate for president
of the United States at the time had
authorized the go-ahead for that meeting
to take place with his son more
humpty-dumpty CNN fake news and
according to BuzzFeed one of the unnamed
sources in the report was Cohn attorney
Lanny Davis he's now completely
backtracking on his claims to fake news
CNN he says that his client in fact does
not have information of Trump's
knowledge of the 2016 Trump Tower
meeting he's saying that CNN's anonymous
sources including himself we were wrong
and after all Michael Kohn testified
under oath this is all coming out that
he had no knowledge of Trump's
involvement in that meeting or anything
else and we also have a new wrinkle in
the story when CNN published their quote
bombshell report they wrote that Lanny
Davis declined to comment in an article
where he was the primary source that's
fake news at its worst
now tonight CNN is actually laughably
standing by that horribly flawed story
spokesperson even said to us they are
confident in their phony reporting it
seems like a perfect story for some
members media reporters at CNN but I
guess they're probably too busy watching
this show every night because they can't
even watch their fake news network and
their own terrible reporting that comes
from them every day
now the debacle surrounding Lanting
Davis is just the latest in a long line
of faulty reporting from fake news CNN
2017 3 CNN employees resigned after a
fake story about our friend Anthony
scaramouche II a few months later CNN
was slammed and publicly embarrassed
over a fake report about Donald Trump
jr. and let's never forget CNN's fake
reporting over president Trump remember
when he was with the Japanese Prime
Minister and they were feeding the fish
now since the very moment Donald Trump
announced his run for office CNN has
been
blinded by their hatred and now while
the network ramps up this crazy rhetoric
and faulty reporting to destroy the
president the country is actually
improving by leaps and bounds stock
market breaking new records were seeing
historic low levels of unemployment in
14 states African Americans Hispanic
Americans women in the workforce youth
unemployment the 52 year low and now we
have more great news that they'll never
report consumer confidence today closing
at an 18-year high so much more good
news to report on the economic front
well